[Applause]
people across China are not happy
and their anger exploded on the streets
for several days
[Applause]
from residents fed up with lockdowns in
Far West China
to students at prestigious universities
in Beijing nearly three years into the
pandemic protesters from different walks
of life have been pushed to the brink a
mystery coveted controls that have hurt
livelihoods and stifled the economy
foreign of the largest Nationwide
demonstrations in decades happened in
China and how this Theory creates a
political dilemma for XI jinping's
leadership
the anger was sparked by a fire in an
apartment building on Thursday in a room
Chi capital of the Northwestern region
of xinjiang where officials said 10
people died
[Music]
the next day residents upset by the
deadly fire took their frustrations to
the streets having also struggled with
lockdowns for more than three months
they said coveted restrictions like
barriers had delayed Rescuers officials
said parked cars got in the way of
moving more quickly
on Saturday in a show of solidarity
people in Shanghai held a vigil to mourn
victims of the fire
[Music]
by the evening larger groups began
gathering on a road named after urumchi
which became a center of protests that
followed in the next few days
as the demonstrations expanded a call
for change became louder
the China's strict pandemic measures be
rolled back
[Applause]
by Sunday as protests spread to other
major cities some of the demands turned
political
[Applause]
and pointed directly at president Xi
Jinping
[Applause]
blank sheets of paper also began popping
up at demonstrations to symbolize
protesters Defiance against censorship
while sensors worked quickly to remove
any indication of unrest on Chinese
social media platforms officials set out
to quash any new protests
on Monday the government deployed scores
of officers and police cars lined the
streets of Beijing
plastic barriers went up along the road
where the first protests outside of
xinjiang began
Chinese State media also published
commentaries defending xi's zero coveted
approach saying the policy is essential
for protecting lives
though the streets are quieter and some
pandemic measures in xinjiang and
Beijing have eased since Sunday these
protests present a conundrum for XI who
just secured a norm-breaking third term
and runs a regime focused on stability
if he relaxes covid restrictions that
could lead to a new wave of infections
and a possible spike in deaths among a
large part of the elderly population
that isn't vaccinated
God but if he holds steadfast it could
create deeper grievances against his
leadership
[Applause]
[Music]